[Music]
i took a taxi
there and it was still dark when i got
there it's kind of like entering a space
station or something that you show up
shed all your clothes put it in lockers
go through this vestibule and you come
out on the other side wearing a climbing
helmet a respirator mask and a hazmat
suit
tomas van ghutriv is a photographer
and he's telling me about his first day
on the job for a national geographic
assignment
so the first day i went up the spiral
staircases of the north bell tower these
long long
stone spiral staircases and then you pop
out at one of the levels and you're on
this balustrad or our balcony with all
of these gargoyles the famous iconic
gargoyles it's called of the
gallery de shimei in french and and
they're all sitting overlooking paris
and ferris was sort of twinkling in this
pre-dawn atmosphere you can see the
seine river from there you can see the
eiffel tower
tommaso's view of paris is unique
he's gazing over the city from a place
that has inspired countless artists from
novelist victor hugo to painter omri
matisse to dancer gene kelly
not to mention more than 800 years of
devout worshipers
and then we went up even more spiral
staircases to the very top
of the south bell tower and then you
could sort of see like you know like the
sun rising over over the sun and all of
paris stretched out below you
and directly below me was
the wound of the cathedral the burnt
roof
the debris the charred bits and pieces
melted parts of scaffolding so you get
this double blow of the beauty of this
unique perspective of paris and then i
could see up close for the first time
the level of devastation that had hit
the cathedral
[Music]
in april 2019 a devastating fire
threatened to consume the iconic
cathedral notre dame de paris but since
then a massive restoration effort has
been underway exposing more than eight
centuries of notre dame's history
in its long life the cathedral has been
damaged and repaired
re-envisioned and reconstructed
each time laying down a new layer to its
story and some of those layers are
hundreds of years apart
for example the bells you hear ringing
still hang in the two iconic towers of
notre dame de paris
there are 10 in all and each one has a
name
and a story
there's the lowest bell emmanuel which
dates from the 15th century
[Music]
it was melted down and recast in 1681 by
order of louis xiv
the other nine vowels including
anjonville marcel denis were installed
very recently in 2013.
when all of them ring together they
create a soundscape that bridges the
centuries
[Music]
the bells managed to survive the fire in
2019 they rang on the one year
anniversary of the fire and will ring
again in the future
the evolution of this sacred space has
become apparent to tomas during his
assignment he's been covering the story
for more than a year and it has taken
him to the very depths of the
cathedral's past and to its highest
heights quite literally
[Music]
i'm amy briggs executive editor of
national geographic history magazine and
this is overheard at national geographic
a show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at nachio and
follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
today on overheard we'll hear how a
cathedral is being reborn emerging from
the ashes just as it has done before
and how the legions of people working to
restore it face monumental obstacles to
bring it back to life just as they have
for centuries
more after the break
[Music]
if you think that back in history when
they were building this in the in the
12th century
this cathedral that they were building
must have seemed so huge for the teeny
little village that surrounded it paris
may have been a teeny little village but
in 1163 when construction started it was
one of europe's largest cities at the
time its population was about 40 000
people
the audacity of this project was immense
i mean imagine the construction of a
building that would take almost 200
years to complete
that's the thing that keeps hitting me
and that i can't really get over in the
project is
is just being like fully conscious of
the idea that the people that started
building the cathedral
knew it wouldn't be finished in their
lifetime and i can't really think of
projects that we do today it would say
we're going to start this and we're
going to do it for four generations from
now or five generations from now
when it was finally complete notre dame
would be the tallest structure in paris
for more than 700 years
until the eiffel tower was built in 1889
you can see what an amazing feat it
remains to this day to build a monument
so huge and it feels like it fits the
city now the city is sort of like grown
up to fit notre dum the cathedral stands
both culturally and spiritually at the
very heart of the city and at the heart
of france for that matter since 1769 the
french have called it pois zero which
means that no matter where you are in
france the road signs to paris tell you
how far you are from notre dame it's
kind of this like central vortex of
french history
where so many things have happened
napoleon crowning himself or the french
revolutionaries coming in and blacking
out all the windows and turning into a
temple of reason instead of a church or
the the last uh great reconstruction of
it it's this place that's
that's uh been through the movements of
time and history and yet continues and
it continues because people care about
it people add to it people are inspired
by it so when the fire started on the
evening of april 15 2019
the entire country came to a standstill
hoping that this wouldn't be the end of
their beloved icon
the cathedral was very badly damaged the
iconic spire added in the 19th century
was destroyed and it fell through to the
altar below
two-thirds of the wooden roof was burned
but the organ was saved the stained
glass windows were saved and of course
so were the bells
as a photographer tomas von hutrieff was
uniquely qualified to document this
rebirth
a belgian american who lives in paris
tomas has always used photography as a
way to understand the big picture if
you'll excuse the pun of what it means
to be a part of a place
it's so fascinating to be in this
culture that in many ways is 180 degrees
from my own
and such a wonderful way to enter into
the culture is through uh through a
camera it's kind of like a passport to
get into situations and a lovely pretext
to to show your curiosity and and share
it with people but before tomas could
share his curiosity he had to go on
location and for that he'd need access
little did i know that the access thing
would be one of the most difficult
nuts to crack in my entire photographic
career i would say the top two
of all time since i've been
photographing since 1999 are notre dame
and getting into pyongyang north korea
so just to let you
know
the level of difficulty
so when when maggio called you up it was
like hey do you want to photograph notre
dame
did they mention all of this stuff or
did you learn it after you said yes i
knew
that the access would be a bit trying
uh but i i didn't know how trying it
would be and then as far as the the
safety concerns i didn't know what a big
deal it would be
uh to go through all of this
[Music]
from a technical point of view like
what's the most challenging aspect of it
all the lead poisoning um
mig is what makes the work site very
challenging basically the roof's
covering was made out of lead and the
outer covering of the spire was made out
of lead and so
when it melted basically lead particles
just got everywhere
and and it's toxic for people especially
in large doses and so they set up
extremely strict protocols for entering
the work site had to take a lead
training safety class basically where
you learn
about testing your blood levels for lead
and toxic exposure levels and the best
way to take often is dispose of your
items and then the second thing is
a lot of the work takes place at at
height basically up high either on
scaffolding or hanging on ropes you need
to take a training uh about wearing a
harness and working safely at heights
but eventually with with uh persistence
i got in and it's it's just a whole
other universe in there it's just been
magic ever since then
tomas recalls his first experience in
the cathedral after he had seen it from
the bell tower in the pre-dawn hours
when he finally saw it from the inside
at ground level when you walked in into
notre dame what did you see paint a
picture for me
inside you could look up and see this
gaping hole
up to the sky
with fingers of burnt timber sticking in
at the edges and that is where the spire
had fallen through and just left this
huge gaping hole right in the right in
the very heart of the cathedral so that
that is extremely moving the the first
time you see it because you know if
you've ever been in one of these old
cathedrals just just walking in
your eyes are encouraged by the
architects to look upwards
and then it ends at this devastating
horrible kind of mangled mess of of fire
debris it's very emotional the first
time you go in there and see this
did that initial shock of seeing the
devastation has changed over time for
you
it has because
they're they're cleaning up little by
little now when you walk in
what's shocking is the amount of
scaffolding that is in there there is so
much scaffolding it looks like a space
station or something like that
i guess in any restoration there's you
know some high degree of i don't know
like it's almost like an archaeological
dig what have you witnessed during your
time at notre dame
so
yeah they're like the whole way that
they're treating
this work site is as if it were one huge
archaeological dig it's like you can't
take
one object even if it's completely burnt
and destroyed
off of the cathedral worksite without
sort of tagging it itemizing it
categorizing it
one of the things that struck me as
interesting is that the the stone card
first in the middle ages in order to get
paid would sign their their own
signature or their own mark on the back
of the stones so they would make a
certain style stone that had to fit in a
certain place
the side with the mark is generally put
inside the wall where you can't see it
and so you just see the smooth surface
of these hand-carved stones of course
all these stones have fallen down now
many of them from from the vaulted
ceilings and arches and so you can see
the back side of these stones well now
the scientists and cultural specialists
and historians that are that are working
on it can see okay how many workers did
we have how many different stone carvers
were them
do these same signatures show up on
other cathedrals in europe in germany
and france and so they are able to
reconstruct and peek at information that
they didn't have access to before
oh wow
look there's so many wonderful bits to
touch on there i mean you're getting a
glimpse of the life's work of people who
for the most part largely go
unremembered by history
um and that they're able to trace
their their work throughout europe i
mean that's just that's astounding it's
really amazing
tamas has experienced the cathedral in
ways that probably no one in its long
history ever intended for it to be
experienced from the air
can you talk to me a little bit about
the drones
so
there's there's two aspects to that one
is inside the cathedral especially
when i first arrived before all that
scaffolding was built nobody was allowed
to walk under there because they just
didn't know when it could give out and
so
it was like how could you take pictures
and so i requested permission to fly my
drone in the nave and fly it
next to the nets in the crossing and i
actually got this permission and of
course
i mean i was
really thrilled to do it but also in the
back of your mind it's like okay i don't
want to be you know the person
that like
smacks my drone in the wall and like
tips off this sort of house of cards you
know what i mean this very
gentle and already damaged cathedral and
so the pressure in the back of my mind
was also was also pretty intense in that
sense so how did you overcome that
pressure like i totally get it yeah
i mean i've just done so much uh drone
flying now and some of it and in
difficult conditions that
you just kind of get in the zone and
the images are good but what's really
moving is the video because
the drone video you're just floating
through this space you know kind of like
disembodied cameras just floating where
none of us could actually go only only
the drone could go there so it has a
completely unique perspective
and it sounds like it would be such a
magnificent virtual reality experience
oh my gosh yes yeah if you could rebuild
that in in virtual reality absolutely
tomas also had the chance to fly his
drone above the cathedral which is an
incredible challenge yes it requires
technical skills but the highest hurdle
he had to overcome
was you guessed it access paris is a
extremely restricted uh airspace
you don't see besides for hospital use
helicopters really flying over paris not
like new york where you have people
sometimes commuting or doing tourist
flights with helicopters but the tricky
thing
there is to be able to fly uh
a drone in in central paris you need
lots and lots of permissions and
sort of amazingly everything came
through and i was able to to fly above
the cathedral and really look straight
down
to the damage of the roof and at the
time i did it they hadn't closed the
hole or covered it yet it's now covered
with plastic so if you want to take that
picture now uh from above you won't see
the hole in the in the center of the
cathedral anymore so you had described
earlier what it was like when you first
walked in the cathedral and you saw the
gaping hole in the ceiling from below
what was it like to see it from above
yeah i could i remember the specific
feeling of giddiness that i had actually
when i was flying the drone and just
trying to keep it together because it
was so amazing for my eyes to
to be up there and and to see this
basically you know my hands were on the
little drone controls and i'm like okay
keep it together keep it together here
but
you know you're you're flying past
the towers where you have heads of
gargoyles popping out
you can sit and
ride over the center the exact place
where the spire used to be and look
straight down and even spin the drone
gently around turning and i could feel
and see through the control screen that
these were going to be good images for
tomas this assignment has been all about
access from getting into the cathedral
itself to flying his drone in impossible
spaces when we come back we'll find out
how tomas managed to access the very top
of notre dame from a slightly different
perspective
on ropes
you might not think that you'd need
climbing skills on assignment and notre
dame but for tomas von hutrief it was
just another way to access the massive
and dangerous space
so
strangely enough i grew up near yosemite
national park and so as a teenager i got
into climbing and it was definitely my
my big thing uh in my late teens and and
into my 20s
but i never in a million years thought
that these skills would be needed in
downtown paris like you just can't
imagine and and i was really you know
sort of excited to learn it so when i
had to go and take this harness and
working at heights
safety class these other people you meet
are also climbers and so like bang right
away we're on the same wavelength what
challenges does climbing present as a
photographer in the cathedral with like
the hazmat suit and bringing all your
your equipment up yeah it's it's mostly
it's mostly the gears that have to be
set up to
document any situation so sometimes i
have multiple lenses with me or if i'm
recording video maybe i need a
microphone with me and so i've gotta
sort of drape this over myself with all
of these carabiners and clips and things
like that but here you're really
climbing on the ropes and attachments
themselves you're not pulling yourself
up you know holding onto a gargoyle's
head or something like that so tell me a
little bit more about the connections
that you were making
a lot of people that are just
comfortable up high and like working
with their body
are attracted to this kind of work so it
just happens that on the team are are a
bunch of climbers so they they do work
where the only access is by rope
basically
the workers that tomas is referring to
are rather
non-traditional
they're called rope access technicians
or cordys in french i mean everything
sounds better on francais nespa
these highly trained climbers are
helping to carry out the incredibly
physical work of restoring the cathedral
and they are doing it on ropes
too to be exact
this aspect of the assignment the
climbing turned out to be a way in for
tomas by working closely with the other
climbers he was able to access not only
parts of the cathedral he was also able
to access a part of the local culture
which can be hard to break through
it's like i had my own cliff in the
middle of paris where i could feel the
thrill of heights and the incredible
panoramic views that you get when you're
high up on something and hang out with
these people that were on the same
wavelength that for me were doing really
interesting and highly technical
specialized work
one of the climbers tomas got to know
was kavin de sal
okay talk about someone who loves the
thrill of heights kaveen had worked on
the eiffel tower nearly 1 000 feet in
the air and found it quite peaceful but
notre dame was a whole new experience
for him
so had had you ever been to notre dame
before you started working there
no never
yeah so whoa whoa whoa whoa you're
french and you've never been to notre
dame
i never
never had chance to visit
not today
kavin and his team take on every
imaginable task in the cathedral from
constructing a temporary roof to
repairing beams to vacuuming very high
places
often while wearing hazmat suits and
respirators
it's pretty hard but
the first was pretty hard and after that
it's okay
both tomas and kavin agree that although
climbing inside and around a massive
building isn't exactly like being high
atop a mountain there are similarities
when you're high above paris
on the cathedral roof looking down
do you feel
at peace
yeah yeah it's correct
when you are high
is very
spaceful
it's funny but
it's like my desk
and my desk is pretty it's pretty nice
i have a nice view
and
yeah it's very um
privileged
to be one of the the workers who
starting you know 800 some years ago to
now now you are one of them what does
that feel like all francais
um privilege
[Music]
[Music]
sentiment it's a privilege to be a part
of the family of workers who have
created restored and renovated notre
dame de paris is one shared by so many
who have dedicated their work to the
cathedral
for thomas van ghutriev his assignment
to cover the restoration takes hundreds
of years of hard work by kaveen and
countless others into consideration but
the pressure of living up to eight
centuries of creative inspiration can be
just as daunting
i decided to re-read
notre dame de paris by victor hugo which
is called the hunchback of notre dame in
english of course
and so after i reread the book i was
like you know
hugo this great literary master he used
it as this great inspiration and i was
like here
here i am in this building that inspired
him to do great things like i need to
tap into the inspiration too
in fact when victor hugo's masterpiece
was published in 1831
it set off a flurry of interest in the
cathedral a massive 20-year restoration
was undertaken in 1844 led by architect
eugene villale duke this was the
restoration that produced the gallery de
chamere the new spire and many of the
iconic features that notre dame became
famous for
for tomas seeing the confluence of all
these elements both intact and in
disrepair became the push and pull of a
journalistic drive to document the
restoration and an artistic drive to
interpret it
so how has notre dam inspired you as an
artist
oh i mean it really in many many ways to
think about the flow of history in our
space and time to think about the amount
of hopes and fears and ideas that have
been projected on this place i have to
say
the strongest uh inspiration is actually
kind of what i described to you when i
first walked in the inside and you're
gazing up and you see the huge hole in
the ceiling i mean
those feelings just go straight through
your soul you know and i was also
inspired by the very beginnings of
photography using a 19th century wet
plate camera and i dragged it all the
way up these stairs inside the north
bell tower and i was able to use that
camera and that also just gave me pause
and said you know look at it in a
different way this camera really forces
you to slow down and also forces you to
channel the way photographers used to
work and used to see the world and so
that was just another of layer that made
this assignment meaningful so as a
photographer you say how can i make a
picture
that somehow
transfers or translates or passes on to
other people this feeling that's moving
through me right now how can i
work the light and the angles and
compositions to to get this feeling you
know out of my heart and in
into the image basically so what are you
hoping people take away from your work
at notre dame i really think that
we we should reflect on this place and
and the role that it's had through time
and culture
and history is kind of one of these few
projects on earth that that brings
people together to make something that's
more than the sum of its parts that
makes something kind of an incredible
human creation sometimes we discover
them
you know forgotten in the jungle
somewhere
great pyramids or things like that but
this is a place like that with the same
kind of amazing collective history
that's still going on and forward
tomas didn't always feel this way about
notre dame as a longtime resident of
paris he used to avoid it and the
upwards of 30 000 tourists that it used
to attract each day i would see notre
dame and and want to go to it and then
say oh there's just so many people and
there's somebody selling postcards and
water bottles and this huge line of
people and just say forget it so this is
kind of like a really
rare occasion where i can be a witness
in a place that a lot of people know and
care about
but very few people have access to at
the moment
[Music]
the scale of this cathedral
of time and history can be hard to
fathom
tomas has become so fully steeped in its
many layers that as he points out he has
become a layer himself a hundred years
from now there'll be a photographer like
me that's looking up for old photos of
the last reconstruction of notre dame
well maybe my photos will be stumbled
upon there and they'll have a have a
second life in that sense too
the devastating fire of 2019 may have
added one more layer to the cathedral's
ongoing evolution
but it won't be the last one
as so many who have dedicated themselves
to this building have learned they are a
part of its very long story
[Music]
i'm just happy to be part of notre
dame's incredible story and trajectory
going through history even if i'm a
little part of it
[Music]
if you like what you hear and want to
support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and consider a national geographic
subscription that's the best way to
support overheard go to nachio.com
backslash explore to subscribe
you can read more about the restoration
of notre dame and national geographic
magazine
check out tomas von hutriv's instagram
at tomasvh to see his work including
drone footage of notre dame
all this and more can be found in our
show notes they're right there in your
podcast app
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by marcy thompson brian
gutierrez jacob pinter and alana strauss
our senior editor is eli chen our senior
producer is carla wills
our executive producer of audio is davar
ardulon our fact checkers are robin
palmer and julie beer
hansdale sue sound designed this episode
and composed our theme music this
podcast is a production of national
geographic partners whitney johnson is
the director of visuals and immersive
experiences and i'm your host amy briggs
thanks for listening and see you all
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you